yeah I'm sure you've done many of these
you want to slow down you keep changing
your look so what you're doing and
everything trying to keep it fresh
keeping it fresh well you definitely are
especially in this film
Aaron Sekulow Entertainment Tonight
Canada so Charlie six weeks in the
jungle
Percy years did it sometimes feel like
yours when you were out there you know
it did on occasion and then by the time
it came to us finishing you know I was I
was really sad to be leaving and it felt
like it had gone by in the blink of an
eye really even with bug shrapnel in
your ear yeah you know all of the
hardships you know almost getting hit by
lightning was a bolt of lightning struck
a tree 20 feet from me and knocked me
off my feet one day and then yeah like
you said a bug called into my ear and
bit a hole in my eardrum and all of
those things included just the overall
experience of being in that environment
I just thought was maybe the best
experience of my life I just loved it
that now I understand um you very much
were very dedicated and had incredible
work ethic when it came to Percy in this
character but I also understand that you
maybe went a little too far and didn't
can you keep in touch with your girl the
way you should have while you were on
the road well my girlfriend was the only
one that I kept in touch with I cut out
all contact with my life and no phone
and no phone no computer no email
nothing I just I just took a complete
sabbatical from technology for the
duration of the film but my girlfriend I
would write matters to so it was the
sweet and you know kind of romantic and
yeah it was you know I always just state
the the requirements of this role was
you know you know arguably greater than
I've ever experienced in my career and
in terms of the scope of this
opportunity it was by far and away the
best opportunity I had and I was a
little bit nervous about it so I always
feel you know the whatever you can do to
mitigate the amount of acting required
on any given day and and Forsett had to
into a great sense of law
mean us but also selfishness for this
pursuit this thing how singular he was
in the pursuit of his sense of personal
destiny and so I wanted to try to create
replicate those emotions as readily as I
could in my everyday experience in
making this film to like like I said to
reduce the amount that I would have to
act all right well yeah that's that
immersion I understand now I know your
co-star Robert Pattinson follows the
method process when he's acting and
there's cincin talk about how you didn't
get a chance to bond on the set because
of that have you had a chance to bro
down now yeah yeah I mean you know it's
funny I don't really know Robert that
well I I from the little I know I liked
him enormous Lee and he's a very sweet
intelligent thoughtful man you know I
don't know who really initiated it I had
been very interested in sort of that and
acting exercise that I thought of her
for many years that a relationship but
screen could exist exclusively between
the time between action and cut you know
and so the relationship that Robert and
my characters have in this film
presented an opportunity to implement
that exercise because the characters
meet on screen if they don't know each
other prior to the story and then
because James is such a great director
he'd created environment where for the
most part we shot sequentially so that
relationship could grow and develop
actually on-screen and so I never talked
to Robert about the fact that this was
my intention because that would have
diminished the impact of it but as soon
as I started implementing it I could
tell he recognized immediately what I
was doing and was really happy to go
with it hello I have one more question I
have to ask to enjoy so sue I just love
to ask you there's a beautiful line in
the film that really stuck with me that
there are places that never leave us and
I'd love to know what is the place that
never leaves you what is your place you
know I was so fortunate in my childhood
as my grandmother my mom
mom was one of the premier portrait
artists of newcastle-upon-tyne like all
of the mares and the sort of you know
fancy people of New Castle's who paint
portraits for and she had a cottage that
she would if she had an assignment she
would go and do all of the sketches that
she needed and then she would go to this
little cottage that didn't have running
water it didn't have a toilet in his
very very basic but it had a stream
running by it and when she passed away
so she would go to this cottage to to
paint you know for months on end and
she's really fascinating kind of
eccentric but an amazing lady and when
she passed away my mom and my aunt
inherited that cottage and it became
this like sanctuary to us we would go
there almost every weekend and there was
nothing for miles and miles around so we
were just free from being very young we
were just free to go and explore you
know in that sense of access to the
natural world and time and space to be
able to let one's imagination run
rampant you know was you know I think
it's such a gift for a childhood but
also really formulas if you know like I
I was able to sort of bring forth and
identify who and what I wanted my life
to be through that space you know and so
I you know it we had a really tragic
situation because it's beautifully
decorated all those very rustic she was
a an avid collector of antiques and it
was beautifully decorated
you know rustic sort of farmhouse style
and and then it got broken into and
everything got stolen and it sort of
broke all of our hearts so much that it
didn't have the same magic after that
and we'd moved to a different place and
was harder to get there so we ended up
selling it on my mom and aunt ended up
selling it in my teenage years and it's
been one of my biggest regrets in life
that I didn't have any money we were
really poor they needed the money at the
time but
oh yeah now you can find well I'm trying
to find those places I went back there
recently and to see I just went on a
pilgrimage er when you know drove 600
miles to go and check this place out and
it's been you know it's been you know
it's been modernized a little bit but it
still has the same beauty to it and so I
knocked on the door and I've been
nervous about this but presumptuous to
do it but I knocked on the door and went
to talk to the guy in left of my number
and I said please if ever the point
comes that you want to sell this place
call me first cuz I give you a good deal
yeah